that's not true though there's a lot of
like catholic and like christian
organizations that specifically help
with adoption right no it's not enough
to even
touch the surface yeah put it to put you
this way yeah like number number wise in
the world right there's over 7 billion
people in the world right if you look at
it like this right if everyone was so
wanted to adopt yeah they would not need
there would be no need for no childhood
no no no no no
again so my parents adopted like i know
a decent amount about adoption my
parents gave up a kid for adoption and
my parents they adopted three like three
of my siblings were adopted and the
issue the issue is that it's legally
it's very hard because you can't you
have to make sure that the the parents
are safe well only conservative people
can really adopt i feel in america that
you've got to be like married and be in
a secure relationship not necessarily
not necessarily it is shifting but it's
more so that you need a lot of money
which is what you're doing it's very
difficult to adopt
as well so i feel like it's unrealistic
to say that that will
compensate for those people that will be
giving away their children i mean
50 of um women over 30 are single and
childless like there's a there's going
to be a fertility they don't i don't
want full of that some of them don't
well that's that goes to why they're
trying to like no i'm saying marriage is
getting later and later so there's gonna
be fertility issues coming out like of
course yeah but they do
it the statistics show that people who
marry later in life they have a lower
divorce rate
it's the cases the highest divorce rates
are people who married in younger ages
between 15 and 24 and then also in the
ages between like 24 and and 30. i i
heard the highest marriage when i looked
at it it was between 25 and 30 was
um the highest marriage rate
so where did you get that from the
height what the highest divorce rate
yeah yeah yeah
okay and it was like statistics i was
looking through actually after we had
our chat like i was going on like
different you might you might be i think
it's like kind of like goes hand in hand
yeah yeah yeah yeah because you're doing
divorce right you're doing marriage yeah
sorry i'm not talking about marriage
rates i'm talking about the heart
you're right you're right yeah yeah like
people who get married
younger yeah they have they have higher
divorce rates so i think um it's maybe
not a bad thing like if you're looking
at people who are waiting to get married
but they're actually staying married
like divorce is not nice
especially if you've got kids in the mix
there like it's not a nice thing my dad
is a product of a broken home
like and he always said to us and like
luckily both my parents are still
married they've been married over 30
years like but for a lot of people
that's not the case and it's it's never
ideal and it's not a nice situation to
have to bring kids into so
um i feel like it's a good you know if
the if the sacrifice is okay people are
getting married later in life
well most women can still have kids
going into their 30s so say if you get
married within your 30s like okay great
you can still have kids and you actually
stay 90 percent of your eggs are gone by
30.
35 after 35 they also provide their
facilities to freeze eggs right and
those people who have the money to
facilitate that option will be the
people who are considered to adopt
the wait say that again so the people
who have the money to actually access
the
option of freezing their eggs obviously
because that is very expensive some
expensive procedures yeah a lot of me
not a lot of people do have that type of
option yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
so the same people the same people their
eggs are the same ones that are able to
how much does it cost to give birth in
the united states
i found out that that wasn't free like
yesterday i was like yeah
if you made a choice to have sex you you
should deal with the kind of imagine
you're 16 you don't even have like but i
think i i do agree with that but i think
that's the separation
at a time one at a time go ahead i think
that's a separate issue in america
because just i i honestly i think
everything in america is [ __ ] up but
no that's true because obviously
in america like you pay for like
everything the only thing that's for
example when you go to a shop to buy a
simple drink right
you get taxed on that and then that tax
is supposed to go to your like healthy
and whatever but you go in to do
anything you can dance whatever i'm
saying just in general like um like if
you want to go um
sorry like get a dental whatever you
pay like your insurance but like you
still pay for that treatment and it's a
lot of money so giving childbirth i
would assume would be a lot of money i
don't disagree that it's expensive sure
but like again you you made that choice
like i'm 25
i've never gotten pregnant okay and then
do we punish the women who aren't
financially stable enough to actually
like what if you can't pay to have about
like yeah
you want to have a kid you want to have
a kid
you realize what that's doing that's
like
saying that like poor people's lives are
less valuable than written down
because people have to make it because
let me finish because they're the ones
you would be aborting because those are
the ones who would be aborting more in
this scenario so it's like you're
insinuating that they're less valuable
and they deserve life less simulating
their experience is completely different
to more wealthy people which are more
likely to be conservative right because
like someone that comes from a poor
background has to make a choice
and we're going to be like completely
financially unstable they're making a
choice to give birth when i don't have
the money to pay for the birth itself
right i'm gonna get go like that's
already like i'm gonna start right in a
terrible position so why would you put
yourself in that situation but they're
not putting themselves in that situation
no but yeah she's gonna say that because
that if you know that you don't have the
means then you shouldn't be having sex
it's it's not viable to say that anyway
because at the end of the day if we are
talking about biology it's natural
innate to
have sex right right but then also to
the people who are we are talking of the
lower class and don't have the access to
go get an abortion these are also the
same people or sexual health care yeah
that don't have
the
the um what's the what i'm saying
resources to prevent that from happening
like contraceptive pills like condoms or
abstinence but in abstinence isn't it an
effective um they've already shown but
this is the other thing that education
the sexual health education in england
is terrible but the sexual health
education
in america is way worse and it varies
state to stay overall overall education
is better what what education do you
need you know if you have sex you are
going to get pro like you have the
option to get pregnant you know there's
con like i'm sorry i
okay i went to catholic school we had no
sex ed
but it's it's just common sense well
you're a smart girl so it might seem
like common sense but i'll tell you
there's some people that really don't
really don't know stupid i'm really
clueless and if no one tells them
they'll okay you're telling me there's
15 year olds that have no idea you can
get pregnant
i'm not gonna say get pregnant internet
today come on no no no get pregnant but
like they will think like oh like
i only need to do this on this day like
some people are like oh you can't get
pregnant on your period like small like
misconceptions can get you pregnant like
if i have sex and water like some people
think certain things
that logically if you're educated you
wouldn't get to that point
but these are misconceptions that a
young person can make easily without the
right education
so
but you think so if i'm driving a car
okay
and i don't know like and i accidentally
hit someone but i didn't know i could
accidentally hit someone should i be
derived right you wouldn't have a
license but you don't have a license
outside that would be the consequence of
not having the license yeah correct the
same consequence of them not having the
resources to not no i'm saying the
consequences if you if you make your bed
lie in it like we have so many forms of
contraception that a lot of people can't
access
not kind of if you don't have a bed to
make wait where are they free
but i'm like
saying that like
or or don't have sex like i was a virgin
throughout all of high school yeah like
i went half of college like oh you grew
up with different values i feel like if
you grow up in a catholic home you maybe
you talk like absence is a good thing
and you can see there's virtue in that
and you see that that's a good thing
what if you don't grow up in that
environment you have no idea okay
abstinence could have some value it
might and you don't see celibacy as
something you want to try well then
you're just not going to think that way
that's fine you don't have to be
celibate but i'm saying like it's it's
about the consequence it's about taking
responsibility for the situation i think
accountability is like always important
but i think like to a certain degree
like
getting pregnant is i think sometimes
there's a lot of misconceptions with a
young a lot of young women and young men
have that can lead to a pregnancy if
they're not well educated or from a poor
background so i just think it's not
right to say that they should always
make their bed and lying in it because i
would say an abortion as well is not you
shirking your responsibility that's a
very grown up and mature decision for
someone to have to make it's not a nice
decision no i don't think it's an easy
decision yeah you realize when they
survey women on why they got the
abortion like or why they got pregnant
85 percent say for no reason yeah
because
85 say no reason because i don't think
they actually do want to say the reason
do you know i mean what is their
business to be actually given why okay
why do i have to tell you why i want to
get an abortion do you know what i mean
i don't feel like i should give you a
reason it's my body it's my choice 85 of
them that's why 100 i still don't even
put my religion down i went to a miracle
and i remember filling out i remember
let me pull this up i want to make sure
i'm quoting this right i remember
filling out um i've never been in the
position where it says white american
sorry black afro-american
and something else and that was the only
options i'm never yeah do you know what
i mean so it's like when it comes down
to it i'm always gonna put other because
i don't feel like i have to tell you why
am i why do i have to tell you my race
when i'm coming into school to get
education that's supposed to be free to
everyone i'm just supposed to give
access to everyone why should i have to
tell you why i'm going to get an
abortion no i yeah i hear what you're
saying but that's that's not how surveys
typically work like the majority of the
time people fill it out the answers like
i just i just think you're saying that
because you don't like the narrative no
i just so
a lot of people nowadays don't feel like
they should give a reason for their
actions
90 you're telling me
[Music]
2 of the people that took the survey
thousands of people ninety-two percent i
do think that's about that okay it is a
survey so it's like valid but you've got
to think about it you're taking a survey
from someone who just had an abortion
think about that like are they gonna be
very receptive
they're just going to want to get you
like okay no reason let's go
they're already hormonal yeah like i
don't feel like you've got to think
about situations but this is good
i'm saying this is evidence and it's
like this is evidence right and they've
done multiple different studies on this
multiple different surveys where the
majority of the responses are no reason
and it's like when i present to you guys
evidence you're like oh don't believe
the evidence of people self-reporting
something and that they choose to be
part of that i'm not saying not believe
it i'm just saying i don't think the
evidence it has holds
um validity in regards to
truthfulness yeah i mean self-reporting
is complete it's not objective it's
self-reporting is so subjective and also
i would like to say like a how how big
is the study but also
who if if i chose to ask you and then
i'd say i wasn't i wasn't raped okay in
theory
sorry i wasn't great
and in theory i don't have enough money
oh it's and it's nothing to do with that
maybe i just don't want to have a kid or
maybe maybe that's my reason what the
hell is wrong with that that's selfish
because right like that's so selfish why
can't why do i have to
have it why do i why do i have to put
myself at risk
it's not putting you yourself at risk
but there's there's adoption you can
give up the kid but no i'm saying that
because
i think giving birth giving birth
actually
kills a lot of women especially black
women
i don't have stats for that but i do
know that like a lot of black women uh
in america die during childhood
regardless of black women women in
general
rather than actually having an abortion
people abortion is such an easy process
even though easy in the sense of
physically emotionally and it can be
draining i understand but at the same
time it's so much more safer than the
woman actually given birth yeah but
that's my point and i'm saying that
specifically because you are a black
woman
um and i'm saying if we are in america
obviously we're in england but if we
were to be in america and your argument
is that uh you are like it is
you're gonna face certain difficulties
um
by
having a baby
you would be at a higher risk in this
scenario because you are a black woman
and you're not going to be taken
seriously in the um in the medical field
yeah so
that's just yeah
10 out of every 100 000 pregnancies what
that died in childbirth no no but look
at the stats for how many black women
but that's what's recorded i'm not
saying that unless yeah i think there's
no stats are valid but that's just in
the u.s and that's not talking no that's
the uk actually
out of every 100 000. no that's actually
quite a lot yes
no because a hundred thousand that's
actually quite a lot i find but no but
my fewer than ten minutes like seven
million guys one at a time please one at
a time please black women in america
so what
what percent of of pregnancies do you
think end in death for black women in
america
a lot more than it should happen
and i'm not saying that as like uh to be
vain or like oh i don't want to give an
answer i'm saying that like and i feel
like in a lot of these answers your
your answers will be different as you
are a white woman in america so you
wouldn't be privy to these because
you're not going to be affected you're
not a black woman you'll never be a
black woman and
if
it just is it's not going to hit the
same for you because it's not hitting
your home
it is true though because i have
actually i've seen this statistic this
is quite widely no you're right it's
higher it's higher so tell them this but
it's still it's still less than one
percent
but that's what i'm saying you're
looking at you're looking at it from a a
country that actually has the resources
and the country that actually well
because we're talking about the u.s
that's where roe versus where i thought
we were talking about abortion in
general well i mean
sort of but like let's let's say us and
uk because that's that's where we're at
okay but then at the same time
and we can we couldn't because they
argue us in the uk
are very developed countries even even
today like we have the highest stan even
people poor today of the highest
standard of living ever in history
because the thing is like we've had um
what was it i think we had like a couple
podcasts ago and perhaps you mentioned
this um
basically in the in the uk any i think
in the uk at least um they shouldn't
really
be
unplanned pregnancy type thing because
we have we
as as bad as our nhs is we have access
to free like contraceptions so whether
like
we do go and like we have on unprotected
sex that's really like
on the man and the woman because like
you know i mean whereas like we have
like the free condom we have okay we do
have a pill and like
i get what you mean
but most of abortions happen quite like
like quite young it's like under 20. oh
my god so a lot of them to do with like
predatory behavior so it's not normally
the woman or the person that's going to
be carrying the baby
that was in the naive situation it's
normally somebody else that's in that
person's life
that took advantage of this person
and then like to always like to expect
that level of responsibility and
accountability for someone that's
probably under 20 years old
i would say on the six are you are you
sure that's the majority of abortion i
don't think i think i think the majority
of abortions happened uh under the age
of 20
and are due to predatory behavior yeah i
was like with an older person i would
say the majority of rape and sexual
assault in what under the age of 18 or
in what concepts are you talking about
the predatorial thing are you talking
like i'm talking about talking about
grape or are you talking about like
just going out i'm just i'm talking
about i'm talking every day guys one at
a time i'm talking generally that um
it's normally like a woman that's in i
feel like a naive situation i think
there's a lot of predatory behavior that
happens that leads to
an unplanned pregnancy also i'd like to
raise the point one of my friends put
this actually on facebook the other day
like she said that um she was a baby
that was born out of a condom
uh the pill and the morning after pill
and all three of those failed and she
was still she like you know she's still
here she's thriving she's alive
obviously but um so even even with
contraception is not 100 okay but
but you're looking for the exception and
not the rule contraceptions per is works
99.99
of the time yeah so so that's that's
like it kind of takes away from the real
argument
because you're looking for the one-off
cases and same with grape that's that's
the exception it's not the rule but why
do we why do we go okay so you made a
mistake or you were naive or you didn't
take this contraception now we're going
to punish you forever because that's
basically what you're doing when you
withhold
the right to an abortion no i think i
think you weren't naive i think you're
irresponsible and i think you could have
you could have made you could have made
better choices and not been in that
situation
and and my mom was in that situation
what about
when my mom was in that situation she
was 17 she had no money she was broke
and she she did the right thing she gave
my brother greg up for adoption i see
him today he's like 30 he's got he's
married he's a software engineer it's
like how are you going to say that's not
a life but how do you think that's the
right thing yeah like why because
because i think life is intrinsically
valuable right but then that means if
that's so you believe in obviously
pro-life yeah right
what was the reason for that it's
interesting
no no because i i think conception
begins at like i think life begins at
conception right but there's also
scientific
evidence that actually shows that
actually a bunch of collective cells
don't represent the human life well why
you know when you conceive a child like
it has a unique genetic coat
so you can see what eye color it has you
can see the personality that it's going
to have you can see like all these
different genetic features that that
kid's going to have at the moment of
conception
and like the brain starts to develop
develop immediately
there's brain activity in the first
phase
but human a human being isn't actually a
human being until the brain is actually
developed and
actually have cognitive behavior do you
know what i mean such as crying such as
um
pain okay so what about someone that's a
vegetable like like that they don't know
i'm serious so if if they need to have
cognitive behavior what about something
definitely
again you're looking at the exception
and not the rule no but i'm talking
about the the academic argument so i'm
talking about like if if your argument
is that it has to have to be like full
of life they have to be able what was
the word you used
um cognitive behavior yeah cognitive
behavior if that's if that if that
determines life then what about this
being the vegetable yeah so like like is
there life not does that not count as
life of course it counts as life but
some people do say
that what is the value of a person who
is